sam bankman fried grew his net worth to
22 billion dollars in just two years and
somehow he can't manage to tie his own
shoes seriously he went to the united
states capital to testify about
cryptocurrency and couldn't even lace up
his shoes correctly so how did someone
who looks more like the ceo of faze clan
than a wall street banker build one of
the largest cryptocurrency exchanges in
the world well after graduating from mit
sam joined jane street capital one of
the largest trading firms in the world
jane street is a market maker which
means they're constantly buying and
selling securities to provide liquidity
for the stock market the margins are
razor thin but jane street makes up for
it in volume in 2020 the company traded
17 trillion dollars worth of securities
and made billions of dollars in profit
and jane street doesn't only trade
domestically they're also the market
maker for many international etfs for
example there are south african index
funds that are listed on the new york
stock exchange thanks to jane street
this allows american investors to get
exposure to these companies without
interacting directly with the
johannesburg stock exchange
international markets can offer big
rewards but they're unpredictable you
have to deal with exchange rate
fluctuations and time zone differences
as well as each country's legal and
financial system so it turns out many
countries have something like a 10 to 50
basis point tax on every trade that
happens on their stock market in some
countries a stock will pay a dividend
then three months later they'll tell you
how big the dividend was you know you
never know exactly what exchanges are
going to do like i don't know sometimes
they'll shut down or shut down stocks
and be like so you can't trade this for
the next month this chaotic environment
can be challenging but also create
opportunities it moves a little bit more
towards the wild west there's all these
things that make it messy and any one of
them if it were the only thing you'd be
like yeah whatever you can adjust for
that but when you add like 20 of them
together all of a sudden you're like oh
god like the market is disagreeing with
me trading in international markets was
no doubt hard work but it taught sam how
to find opportunities with asymmetrical
risk these are situations where your
downside is 1x but your upside could be
unlimited and soon enough such an
opportunity presented itself to sam
[Music]
in 2017 he discovered that bitcoin was
trading at a premium on korean
cryptocurrency exchanges if the price of
bitcoin was ten thousand dollars on
coinbase it could be as much as fifteen
thousand in korea this happened so
frequently that traders started
referring to the phenomenon as the
kimchi premium in theory you could
arbitrage this buy bitcoin in the united
states transfer it to a korean exchange
sell it for korean wan transfer the
money out from korea back to the us and
make a 30 to 50 profit on each trade but
this strategy wouldn't scale because
korean capital control laws limit
foreign transactions over five thousand
dollars however sam found a similar
opportunity in japan the premiums were
lower only five to twenty percent above
u.s prices but this could still prove
immensely profitable sam knew that he
had to move fast together with gary wang
who had been sam's roommate in college
he founded a trading firm called alameda
research and raised 1 million dollars
from personal savings and close friends
but there were a bunch of hurdles to
overcome before alameda could take
advantage of the japanese arbitrage
opportunity exchanges were backlogged
and it took weeks for sam to get a
coinbase account and once he started
depositing money in coinbase his bank
shut down his account back then the
traditional financial sector wanted
nothing to do with cryptocurrency sam
also needed a bank account in japan so
we hired a lawyer to go to the bank and
explain what alameda was doing it didn't
go well though and then you're like all
right can we send this to the asset like
what are we doing with it uh it's crypto
trading to like can you repeat that what
sam was trying to do was a red flag for
any bank actually every single day i
would like to send like five million
dollars in the same direction it's only
going one way
to a different country
and it's a different entity this is the
sketchiest [ __ ] thing i've ever seen
alameda did manage to get a japanese
bank account but this was just the start
the price delta couldn't last forever so
alameda wanted to repeat the trade as
many times as possible before the
opportunity disappeared every day sam
and his team would execute these eight
steps one wire us dollars to coinbase
two buy some bitcoin transfer that
bitcoin to japan then sell the bitcoin
in japan for yen convert that yen to us
dollars finally wire those dollars back
to the u.s bank account it was a
complicated loop with zero margin for
air and it was made worse by the fact
that the bank had a terrible user
interface that would only let you
convert a hundred thousand dollars at a
time you know when we're at this like
converting step um and took a minute per
hundred thousand dollars so we just all
stopped doing we all broke out on our
computers they're just like clicking
through eventually like when we had like
one minute left we were like all right
guys it's time whatever that is that no
more sam would then notify an alameda
employee who was waiting at the bank in
japan that person would walk up to the
teller and say that they wanted to make
a wire transfer and like to wear and
like that all the details and like
watched i say typed in like the
reference you know looks like [ __ ]
reference numbers yeah if everyone's
like three q seven t is like no it's a g
not a t but you gotta cross that out to
g not a t and then eventually hopefully
they submitted before the cut off that's
if you lost 24 hours alameda could only
do this trade for a few weeks before
other traders caught on and the
opportunity went away but they still
made a pretty massive amount of money
around 20 million dollars this would
help them lay the foundation for
building alameda into a true trading
powerhouse now the japanese trade hadn't
been particularly complicated so they've
done everything in excel spreadsheets
but going forward sam wanted to speed
things up using proprietary trading
software so he focused on hiring top
technical talent to help him grow the
firm the average alameda employee is not
unlike sam in their twenties has a stem
degree from a top university and
previously worked at a wall street
trading firm while a homogeneous team
like that can occasionally have
drawbacks it simplifies teamwork and
communication in a business that depends
on fast decisions understanding each
other without saying anything is
valuable the combination of team and
technology has enabled alameda to become
one of the largest crypto trading firms
they now trade 5 billion per day and
make 1 billion per year in profit with
only 22 employees every employee
generates tens of millions of dollars in
profit making alameda one of the most
profitable firms in the world on a
profit per employee basis
while running alameda sam tested out
different cryptocurrency exchanges and
he discovered a number of issues
especially when trading derivatives
first most exchanges had terrible
liquidation engines a liquidation engine
is the software that calculates when to
liquidate someone's position if they've
used leverage and are now underwater
seems simple in theory but in reality
many exchanges failed to liquidate the
position in time which allowed losses to
compound and the user's wallet balance
to fall below zero and this wasn't a
minor problem top exchanges were losing
up to 1 million dollars per day due to
inefficient liquidation engines
exchanges didn't want to eat the loss
themselves so instead they confiscated a
small amount of money from each user's
account on the platform additionally
exchanges treated every cryptocurrency
you owned as separate collateral which
added unnecessary complexity that you
should have 500 different wallets within
a single exchange that like if you want
to trade ethereum futures and then you
want to trade bitcoin features you gotta
buy some meat then put it in your eat
wealth and take it out trade for bitcoin
put in your bitcoin wallet it's just
like this useless mini game that like
half your time is spent dealing with
your collateral you know and people
getting liquidated left and right they
forget about one of their wallets even
though bitcoin had been around for over
a decade the cryptocurrency ecosystem
was still the wild west many small
exchanges generated fake volume to
increase their rank on websites like
coin market cap sam's team did a case
study and detected over 60 exchanges
that were faking volume one exchange uh
just took binance's trades and repeated
them a third of a second later uh so you
would see
a b b tether trade print on binance and
then 300 milliseconds later a b b tether
trade at exactly the same price
printed on that exchange sam knew his
team could build a better exchange that
fixed all of those issues he wasn't sure
if users would come but he figured there
was at least a 20 probability that ftx
would succeed the potential payoff was
huge so it was worth trying starting a
cryptocurrency exchange in the u.s takes
a long time so sam moved to hong kong
which at the time was very crypto
friendly oh and when i say that sam
moved to hong kong it wasn't like he had
this big elaborate months-long planning
process beforehand one day he just
happened to be in hong kong for a crypto
conference and liked the vibe so a few
days later he rented a wework office
space and told the rest of his team who
at the time were still based in
california to fly to hong kong as soon
as possible once they got there they
bought whatever monitors were available
at the nearest computer store set up
their workstations and got up and
running like nothing had happened
considering that this is the speed at
which this team operates it's no
surprise that ftx was able to go from
idea to launch in just six months this
is late 2018 at this point and we
launched spring 2019. the initial code
for the exchange was written by just two
engineers and apparently sam's
co-founder gary wang wrote ftx's risk
management software by himself in just a
few weeks but even though the team moved
at light speed they never compromised on
quality from day one ftx's trading
experience not only matched that of
established competitors but blew theirs
out of the water ftx offered the lowest
fees as little as 0.03 per trade they
had the highest maximum leverage
initially up to 101 x although they
later reduced the maximum threshold to
20x and their derivatives products like
futures and leveraged tokens were
quickly adopted by traders ftx
immediately took off by the start of
2020 ftx facilitated 30 billion dollars
of transactions per month one year later
monthly volume reached 120 billion and
by summer of 2021 the monthly volume
surpassed one trillion dollars and these
trading volumes resulted in some
incredible revenues for ftx in 2019 they
were making forty thousand dollars per
day and by 2021 they were making over
two million dollars per day hyper growth
puts pressure on every area of the
company though so when it comes to
expanding the team sam always aims for
quality over quantity ftx started out
with 10 employees and even today it has
just 200 employees sam likes people who
are independent move fast and take
responsibility it's better to have just
one really great lawyer than a massive
committee that gets nothing done like
you can you can hire 3000 lawyers to
argue with each other all day about you
know proposed legislation in in some
jurisdiction and like fail to address
important parts of your kyc policy the
same goes for customer support
engineering and other departments sam
trusts his team to always do the right
thing but he still takes time to
understand all aspects of the business
at a very deep level for example he
personally tests every user onboarding
flow himself every time that i try and
walk myself through it i'm annoyed at
something this helps him understand
what's going on and give good feedback
in meetings with employees but we still
need to talk about regulation sam
recently moved both alameda and ftx to
the bahamas because of its strong
cryptocurrency legislative framework in
december of 2020 the government there
passed new legislation which set clear
standards for digital asset exchanges
having a country that we're excited to
work with and is excited to work with us
is super valuable it is valuable from
you know everything from hiring here
immigration quarantine regulation
licensing banking and and just a lot of
other things so it's a really nice place
to be in sam wants other crypto
companies to move their hqs to the
bahamas and transform this caribbean
island nation into a thriving crypto
ecosystem and he really means that ftx
has already donated 10 million dollars
to various organizations in the country
including charities and universities and
they're building a 100 million dollar
headquarters that is scheduled to break
ground soon apart from being an
international financial hub the bahamas
also offers good flight connections to
the us miami is just 55 minutes away
when ftx started they focused on serving
international customers and avoided the
us because of its strict regulations
today most of ftx's customers are in
europe and asia but sam wants to grab
market share in the us as well in may of
2020 ftx launched a separate exchange
called ftx us which u.s customers can
access while the us market has
established competitors most of them are
focused on spot trading and don't offer
derivatives ftx us wants to change that
last october they acquired a crypto
futures exchange called ledger x and now
offer derivatives trading on ftx us
sam's plan here is to grow into the
largest crypto exchange in america over
the next two years to accomplish this
he's gone on a spending spree to improve
visibility in the us market last june
ftx acquired the naming rights of the
esports team tsm for 210 million dollars
it's now called tsm ftx one month later
ftx paid 135 million dollars for the
naming rights of the miami heat nba
stadium and one month after that ftx
forked over 150 million to buy
cryptocurrency price tracker at
blockfolio blockfolio has 6 million
customers many of whom could soon be ftx
customers and this marketing strategy
seems to be working ftx us grew their
user base over a hundred x in 2021. ftx
is quickly expanding into many new
business lines ftx pay is a low fee
payment processor that accepts
cryptocurrency they now have a
marketplace for trading nfts which they
actually use to sell an nft that comes
with the right to have lunch with sam
which is kind of funny and they also
have a 2 billion vc fund that will
invest in crypto web 3 and gaming
startups sam wants to build an exchange
where you can trade not just
cryptocurrencies but anything ftx now
enables you to trade tokenized versions
of stocks like tesla nvidia and google
and since ftx is open 24 7 you can trade
those companies whenever you want even
if the stock market is closed you can
also trade futures tied to the outcome
of u.s and brazilian presidential
elections as well as futures for
commodities like lumber non-crypto
trading is still a tiny part of ftx's
business but there's no sign that sam is
slowing down anytime soon there's still
one thing that makes sam really stand
out from other wealthy traders though
and this detail has determined every
action sam has taken over the last eight
years of his life sam and many alameda
and ftx employees are members of a
movement called effective altruism
effective altruists try to maximize
their positive impact on the world some
go to work for a non-profit with a good
cause such as lobbying for better
treatment of farm animals others choose
a strategy called give to earn where you
go into a well-paid career and then give
a portion of your income to
high-efficiency charities sam plans to
make a bunch of money and then just give
it away and sam has already taken the
first steps toward this ftx currently
donates one percent of net trading fees
which has totaled over 17 million
dollars and even though sam doesn't
spend much time in political circles he
donated five million dollars to biden's
campaign in 2020 which made him one of
its top donors sam's rationale was
simple political donations can have a
thousand x leverage the politician who
gets elected sets the direction for how
the government spends money during a
four-year term the president will
control trillions of dollars in
discretionary spending but the total
spending for all the candidates in the
2020 presidential campaign was just a
few billion dollars that's less than one
tenth of one percent so far sam has only
given away 50 million dollars but now
that he's a multi-billionaire he'll
start giving away bigger portions of his
wealth every year he plans to donate 500
million dollars this year and just a
decade from now he estimates that he
will have donated more than 10 billion
dollars in total sam has made tons of
money from pretty much every
cryptocurrency imaginable but he's
always been particularly excited about
solana to find out why just go and watch
this video about the fascinating history
of that project thanks for watching
[Music]